[Music]
my relationship to
self-improvement or thinking about hacks
and so on has changed over time
and you know the word hack used to not
have as much baggage
as it now does so i use that term
uh effectively never these days uh
because it's just established
such a or taken on such a kind of a
nasty
negative overtone but
i'll tell a story i think this
illustrates how i'm
reorienting quite easily and that is
spending time
with an incredible i want to say
psychiatrist
he's also i want to say an ordained
minister i may be getting some of the
details wrong here maybe it's a masters
of dfinity i don't know
uh named bill richards and
bill richards is well known also for
being
one of the most experienced let's call
it
guides or facilitators above ground in
the psychedelic
world so he's facilitated hundreds of
sessions along with
a woman named mary cosimano who's
who's equally impressive in so many ways
and just an
incredible human being and i spent time
with bill
he he supervised years and years of
sessions both
pre-prohibition meaning pre the
uh controlled substances act and post
uh so he's done all sorts of trainings
all over the world
and there were there were two things
that stood out from that conversation
immediately number one i asked him what
books he could recommend
for learning more about the process of
guiding the protocols they used that
he said well so you know the problem
with books and i was like
what's the problem with books and he
said too many words
again it gives you an idea of his
personality and then the second
thing he said was related to doing the
work
you know because i said i'm not afraid
to do the work
and he said well you know what's so
tricky about doing the work
then i and i i asked him
what it was that was so tricky and he
said well
there's a very thin line between doing
the work and just picking on yourself
so i think that you know
self-improvement and
how much it affects you positively or
negatively for me personally depends a
lot on the motivation behind it right
like are you
running away from something are you
running towards something
are you finding problems with yourself
or problems in your life just because
you've been rewarded throughout your
life as a problem solver i think that's
true for me it's true for a lot of
people
you're just good at solving problems you
get really good at finding problems
or are you doing it because there's some
joy in doing it
right so for instance right now i'm
trying to pick up a couple of different
games like board games
chess there are a number of things and
i find those really fun so i'm improving
my thinking
and so on looking at a game of complete
information like chess
learning about classical games and all
this stuff legal's mate i think is one
that i learned yesterday
which is just gorgeous with uh
tonight and i'm a novice but i'm having
so much fun doing it
versus let's just say
a contrast with that would be a therapy
session that i had
yesterday where we got into all this
childhood stuff
and revisited a bunch of trauma and i
came out of the session
feeling much worse than when i went into
it
and uh it occurred to me that i think
that
we can feel like we're doing a good
thing sometimes
when we're suffering
and grinding but that does not by
default
mean that we're doing something
worthwhile or improving
and so after that session i
i sort of committed to myself not to
like dredge up
all of the pain from the past in the
name of doing the work just because i
can
so i feel like i have a very good
relationship to
hacks and all that stuff now it doesn't
cause me stress and in fact it never
really has
but i think for a very long time
i looked for problems to solve because i
was good at solving problems
and not all of those problems were
worthwhile
and many of those problems were just
masochistic
you